night city the place everyone wants to
be
the night city of cyberpunk 2077 is full
of danger and opportunity
where corporations control everything
from their luxury towers
while the gangs rule the streets it's a
place where you can carve out your
legend and stand next to the many grapes
or wind up dead in a gutter but that's
not how night city started out
it began as a simple dream by one man to
create the city of the future
a future that he never got to see
realized
so let's turn back the clock to the
founding of night city
and discover its bloody origins
much of our information on the creation
of night city is sourced from an
article as part of the night city
celebration of its 25th anniversary
written by dr edward michaels the dean
of night city university at the time our
story begins with one man
richard knight during the 1980s and
early 90s
knight was an ambitious businessman with
an eye for architecture
and urban planning he was a partner and
the construction firm
halsey ferris and knight which
specialized in the creation of corporate
funded projects
their reliability and impressive
standards of quality made them a go-to
for many corporations and they
raked in the profits however this status
wasn't enough for knight who eventually
grew bored of designing
simple office buildings he was a
visionary with a dream of something
far more ambitious so in 1990
knight left halsey ferris and knight to
start his
own firm knight international there he
would begin drafting up plans for the
ideal
american city one that knight hoped
would shape the future and become a
template for all
cities that followed it was around this
time that the collapse was entering
full swing it was a mass decline of
economies and societies not just in
america but around the world
things were changing quickly and in the
chaos the mega corporations
swooped in filling the power vacuum left
by the failing american government
many began taking control of america's
once great cities
carving out their own pieces of the
united states for themselves
but this was easier said and done as
many of these cities were in ruins
and much work needed to be done to
wrestle them under control
it would be a lot easier if a
corporation could build a city from
scratch
molding it from the ground up to suit
the purposes of those that controlled it
and this is where night city of the
future came in
he needed the capital to make his dream
a reality and the mega corpse wanted a
city for themselves
it was a match made in heaven investors
flocked tonight
and by 1992 arasaka ebm
and petrochem all backed his project in
particular the backing of petrochem
ended up being of particular fortune for
night knight was already searching for
land to build on the central california
coastline
as it turned out petrochem owned most of
the region of del coronado bay
which sits comfortably in between san
francisco and santa barbara and was the
perfect spot
for knight's vision after acquiring the
rest of the surrounding area
construction began in 1993 on what would
be called
coronado city unfortunately for richard
knight
he would never see his dream city
completed
knight wanted coronado city to be unlike
any city built before it
he opted to use the most revolutionary
building techniques of the day
as a result this left out a lot of the
old school construction companies from
the project
many of whom were in dire financial
situations
thanks to the collapse this even
included knight's old firm
now known as halsey ferris and skiv who
were in
so much financial strife that they even
made deals with the local mob
the bitterness from his old partners and
the many others who were hoping to be
contracted for the construction of
coronado city
painted a huge target on knight's back
for much of the city's construction
knight would receive resistance from
those who felt slighted by him
with some going as far as threatening
his life
but knight would not be perturbed
brushing off these threats or relying on
his corporate partners to handle them
this lasted for four years before
finally on september 20th
1998 knight's enemies got him
he was shot by an unknown gunman in his
penthouse suite and to this day
no one knows which of knight's many
enemies was responsible for his murder
the nearly completed coronado city was
renamed night city
in honor of the visionary founder
unfortunately the resulting chaos from
knight's death
would cause his dream city to never be
fully realized
the next seven years would be a
tumultuous back and forth between
knights corporate partners who had
invested heavily in the city
and the mob who had swooped in to
control most of if not all of these
street level businesses
by 2005 the corporations gave up
deciding it wasn't worth their time and
instead remained holed up in the
corporate center the heart of night city
this left the mob as the de facto rulers
and started what was later known as the
dark ages
violence became the norm and murder was
at an all-time high
with thousands of unsolved cases the
streets had become
a literal war zone this lasted until
2009 when the corporations eventually
chose to step
in murder on the streets was one thing
but the chaos and mob rule started to
affect the one thing that really
mattered
business corp arasaka led a full-on
paramilitary assault
with soldiers in the streets tanks and
even flyby
bombings known as the mob war this
powerful show of force completely
decimated the mob's power and put the
corporations back in charge
the next eight years were spent finally
trying to bring the city back to a
semblance of knight's original vision
many parts of the city especially those
with major corporate interest
did become that beautiful vision of the
future that knight wanted
a place of innovation and the merging of
many cultures
a city of dreams where anyone can make
it big however
the years of chaos have forever shaped
night city and it is still a place of
dangerous street gangs mob
influence and needless violence this
would be only the beginning of night
city's long
and bloody history and by no means the
worst thing to happen to it
that's the story for another day thank
you for watching this brief look at the
creation of night city
this is only a small part of the city's
vast history and there are many more
stories to tell
if you're interested in learning more
yourself we highly recommend you check
out cyberpunk 2020's
night city source book this book breaks
down everything about night city in the
year 2020 from its street gangs to its
local infrastructure
to even its airport the information you
heard today was sourced from this book
if you want to learn about a particular
part of the world of cyberpunk
give a suggestion in the comments thanks
for watching and we'll see you next time
when we dive into the story
of one of night city's most legendary
figures
[Music]
you